the student debt crisis the student loan
issues and the fact that Democrats are
trying to push to forgive all student
loan debt if they can not not the
Democratic party officially but many
people in the party want all student
loaned up to be forgiven Joe Biden was
pushing for this obviously the Supreme
Court wasn't having it but we see here
uh in some data that was published by
axios here that Young Americans are
likely to blame the Supreme Court and
Republicans for a lack of debt
forgiveness now now here's a radical
idea maybe if you took out loans the
person you should blame for the fact
that you are on debt is not the Supreme
Court and not the Republican party but
yourself that said I'm sympathetic to
some of the arguments that advocates for
student loan debt forgiveness make just
in the sense that if someone's already
paid off more than they actually owed
but because they've been paying it off
for so long enough such a high interest
rate that they're still in the hole I do
think there's something about that which
is upsetting especially considering
these loans are federally guaranteed so
there isn't the same level of risk for
the lenders who are collecting this
massive interest straight I hear all of
that that said it's hard to be
sympathetic when people who
statistically are making significantly
more than people without college degrees
are demanding that those people pay
their debts off for them and people who
also uh are earning at the same level as
people who did pay off their degrees but
had to take less money in the moment in
order to pay that off and they want them
to have their wages redistributed or
their salary redistributed to pay that
debt off so just to give you guys an
idea of the numbers here if you graduate
with a doctorate degree your median
earnings are ninety seven thousand
dollars per year your unemployment rate
is about one percent if you have a
master's degree you're meeting salaries
like seventy seven thousand about 78 000
in your unemployment rate's about two
percent when you get down to somebody
with a high school diploma your median
salary is thirty eight thousand dollars
a year and you have an unemployment rate
of 3.7 percent so people who have
doctors people who have degrees they
make significantly more than people who
don't have these degrees they also are
significantly less likely to be
unemployed so the idea that you could
spend four to six years in an academic
institution even longer than that
depending on the track you were on and
accumulate debt throughout that time
period and then step out into the
workforce after having all you know many
if not all in some circumstances of your
living expenses taken care of through
that four to six years and then enter
into the workforce not having had a job
before but being able to make more money
than people who had a job through that
four to six year period four to eight
year period depending on your track
whatever however long you took uh is
totally insane and totally selfish in my
opinion
part of it I think is that people expect
that if they study something they're
going to be going to be able to get a
job in that field and that getting a job
in that field should be able to pay off
their student loans and I think that
that's short-sighted as well yeah I mean
if you go to college and you study
gender and then you get a degree and you
know philosophy or whatever like why
would you think that you're immediately
going to be able to get a professorship
and pay off your degree with that the
idea is that you go to school sure you
can study what you want but you have to
then get a job that's going to pay your
bills you know with the future that you
met that you make so I think that that's
the I think that the biggest problem is
the unrealistic expectations of the
students who take out these loans I feel
like the loan system and I am not an
economics person but it seems to me like
it's just completely broken I know there
is an argument uh for like you took out
the loan so you know the consequences it
does seem crazy to me that the federal
government gets to say uh you can't
default on this loan and also we will
ultimately decide if if we'll forgive it
or not like this seems like a broken
system if you could default on student
loans would you issue them right like a
bank would take into account if you're
you're getting a loan for a house they
take into account the kind of money you
make your financial history and then
they make a decision does the federal
government take into account what we
need in terms of jobs so like if you're
a nursing student do you get a better
interest rate if you take out a student
loan like are we giving loans to people
where there is also jobs waiting for
them at the end that system seems like
it makes more sense than we currently
have which is like you're 18 and take
out massive amounts of debt to study
whatever you think may or may not based
on nothing make money and be able to pay
off this loan there doesn't seem to be
the same system that we have for every
other type of loan out there yeah no I
totally agree with you I think that if
financial institutions weren't having
these loans uh subsidized they would be
more careful about who they were going
to give loans out to I think other
things might be taken into consideration
if the whole system wasn't rigged by
these federally subsidized student loans
you might even have financial
institutions considering not only the
major person has and the likelihood of
getting a job and what they might earn
at that job if they they graduate but
also the likelihood of them graduating
what kind of student were they in high
school and ultimately I think the loans
would be significantly less expensive
overall the National Bureau of economic
research published a paper several years
ago where they essentially confirmed
that universities and colleges respond
to the widened access and easily
available money by doing guess what
raising the prices
in most of the raises intuition actually
don't correlate Within increased number
of people in The Faculty they actually
hire more administrators yes I know
there are many people living in the Arts
centers build that exactly so I know
many people who've made the arguments
that there are many colleges that
they're they're basically hedge funds
with a kind of educational front built a
top they take this money they invest it
they end up growing their wealth kids
are paying their to get an education
they don't necessarily improve the
quality of that education as students
move through and the tuition goes up and
they're laughing all the way to the bank
and people end up in this this kind of I
don't want to call it debt slavery
because that seems a bit hyperbolic but
they end up owing significant portions
of their income for the foreseeable
future and again the one reason I am not
sympathetic to the people who push for
student loan uh forgiveness even though
I am sympathetic to people with student
loans is because I don't think that
people who made the decision not to go
to college and who are making less than
you should have to bite the bullet or or
also I mean I'm sure we all know people
who took out you know hundreds of
thousands of dollars in student loans
and we also know people who made the
decision to go to colleges that were
less expensive so that they didn't have
to be burdened with that loan debt or
made other decisions about how they were
going to be educated and I think that's
really valid as well I know one of my
cousins very intelligent wanted to go to
a top school decided to go to a state
school had enough money to pay for that
did that and is now not saddled with
student loan debt has a good job has a
mortgage has a couple of kids doesn't
have to pay for school still I think
part of it is the false promise that you
know college is this door to some great
uh you know ladder to the elite or just
more financial Comfort or stability when
that's not the case anymore I think you
can falsely sell to people if you go to
the most elite University you can go to
even if it puts you in hundreds of
thousands of dollars worth of debt you
are guaranteed success in the future and
that's just not the case even though but
it is more likely I mean statistically
the higher degree level is the higher
education level is I wouldn't say you
want to earn more money yes you may as
the as studies show be have uh more
employment things like that but
if you put yourself in debt you always
have that debt it doesn't go away the
first day you would then have to budget
yourself according to me you'd have to
take a job that you can pay it off you
would have to choose a lifestyle that
accommodates this debt and if you don't
want to have to do that you make choices
differently and ultimately you're able
to potentially uh generate wealth more
quickly because you don't have to
immediately overcome this obstacle
you've given yourself which is massive
student loan debt yeah well there's kind
of there's a couple different ways of
looking at this but here's one way I
look at it firstly if you got a degree
that was very useful and you're earning
a lot of money and you're the kind of
person who's student loan debt we would
want to pay off because you're massively
contributing you're making enough money
to pay off your student loan debts right
if you're somebody who majored in
something useless and so you're not
making any money well why would we
subsidize useless degrees you think that
if you forgive student loan debt yeah
you think if we forgive people student
loan debt that's not going to have an
effect on the market that's not going to
have an effect on the number of people
taking out student loans that's not
going to have an effect on tuition costs
of course it's going to it's going to
make the problem worse yeah it will just
declare the student loan debt experiment
dead like that's what I want to know
when can we just really overhaul this
system because it seems broken and even
if they forgave some massive amount of
student loan debts and by some crazy
odds which is obviously unrealistic it
didn't hurt the economy somewhere else
like when do we say like okay we've
learned a lesson this system is not
working we're going to do something else
because ultimately that's what bothers
me the most like but it's even a
collective we don't have a collectivist
approach no I think we should a solution
student loans should not have interest
attached to them that's a huge issue I
think I think if it's federally
guaranteed
interest like I can't you end up having
to pay interest on your interest yeah
children don't understand that yeah but
also I still call it the most powerful
force in the universe we've caught we've
sold them a false bill of goods too like
pursue your dreams and everything will
work out that's total crap not true it's
just a lie I think your dreams have to
like look there's a couple things like
your dreams have to be good they also
have to line up with what it makes the
most sense for you to be doing in the
world right there's so many layers of
this like some people have genuinely bad
dreams right so some people want to do
things that would actually not be good
for the world uh and and then there are
some people who want to do something
good but maybe they're not the best
person for it right there are a lot of
layers to this I think there are a lot
of people who dream of putting in no
effort that's the other yeah well yes
there's sort of a lack of discipline
like I said if if we had to line up a
bunch of 18 year olds and be like hey
you could major in whatever you want but
I'll tell you that these are the
industries that need
workers they have salaries if you get
through this degree you will have money
at the end like there's going to be a
lag there though as soon as you say like
these are the industries where we need
people to come do work it's going to
take what like 10 years for people to
get up to speed in that area and then
things better than nothing though right
and I think part of it is like why don't
we why do we want to make rational
decisions about their future right like
why are we also indulging this culture
of like you could you could do anything
but you then you have to be responsible
for the consequences of that thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time